[Music]
spot tune - is on the horizon and octave
canyon the new single player mode offers
a much more robust and engaging
experience in the first game thanks in
part to a bunch of new creative and
mechanical tweaks we've got a list here
of our six favorite things from the
campaign that make the sequel even more
enjoyable ah there it is
first squid pump four more of those and
also more splatoon to coverage you can
subscribe to our YouTube channel so you
don't miss a thing
alright let's get cracking number one
the Dooleys early on in splatoon -
you're given access to the splat
Dooley's a pair of pistols that
effectively double the firepower of your
starting weapon one of the obvious
advantages of this is that with a gun in
each hand you can cover a wider swath of
space in front of you as you shoot and
one of the most important aspects of
wielding Dooley's is the accompanying
dodge roll mechanic that they enable or
your best bet for avoiding incoming fire
in the original splatoon was to turn
into a squid and hide in the ink the
dodge roll granted by the Dooleys is a
snappier maneuver and can be used twice
in rapid succession allowing you to
quickly avoid enemy ink and pop up fast
enough to return fire number two
grinding swimming through ink is part
and parcel of splatoon and sometimes
that means writing a narrow stream of
ink from one platform to another in the
original spot tune it was a process that
could only be accomplished in a squid
form but splatoon 2 introduces the
ability to stand up and ride Jets of ink
on your heels if you've ever played
sunset overdrive or jet grind radio the
sensation of grinding spittoon 2 will
feel very familiar but whether or not
you get a twinge of nostalgia this
mechanic no doubt enhances your mobility
in splatoon - and is just plain fun in
the process I don't know if anyone asked
for this feature specifically but it's a
welcome surprise that perfectly suits
splatoon - style of movement number
three boss battles
the boss fellows in the first Platoon
were some of the high points in the game
single-player mode so it's no surprise
that splatoon 2 includes some of the
most ridiculous bosses this side of
inkopolis the new inks frein giants that
conclude each world are utterly
ridiculous and will test your knowledge
of the game's weapons as well as the new
mechanics introduced throughout the
campaign the game's first world has a
banger of a boss battle in octo oven the
eight side industrial appliance fires I
Love Lucy sized loaves of bread through
its doors and eventually chases you down
with its donut glaze apparatus and the
second one gets even weirder with a
unicycle writing samurai flinging ink
with this roller katana the vivid colors
and striking character designs make
splatoon twos bosses a joy to fight as
well as a psychedelic assault on the
senses number four charging while
swimming if you like the charger in the
first splatoon it's even more dangerous
in this game you can now swim for a
short period of time while your rifle is
fully charged and when you resurface
your powerful sniper shot is ready to go
this allows you to safely hide in ink
while your opponent is firing at you and
then you can pop up quickly and blasts
them with a one-hit ko shot
the new-and-improved charger shines on
the turf war style levels against a slew
of enemies that are dead set on hunting
you down it's a perfect opportunity to
practice the timing since you'll lose
your charge off for a few seconds in the
ink and it's gained us even more excited
to try it out in the multiplayer mode
when the time comes number 5
grappling lures we've already covered
spot tune 2's new grinding mechanic but
the single-player mode has plenty of
other tricks up its sleeve when it comes
to getting around the map in the second
area of levels you're introduced to
floating lures and these little items
can turn your ink gun into a grappling
hook you generally need a weapon that
can fire great distances like the spa
charger for example to make use of them
basically if your shot can reach all or
you'll be reeled in towards this
location spot tune 2 uses lures in
conjunction with timing based challenges
at first but we're hoping to see them
combined in a level with the grind able
Inc Rails to really open up splatoon
twos newfound appreciation for movement
variety as if swimming wasn't cool
enough already
and number 6 roller speed increase
rolling with the roller in splatoon was
a great way to cover large chunks of
turf to ink even if it didn't make for
the best offensive weapon fast forward
to today and there's been a small but
meaningful update applied to the roller
in splatoon - which while not geared
towards improving the weapons stopping
power does ultimately make you a more
efficient inker now when using a roller
on foot to spread ink on the ground you
can gain a quick burst of speed if you
keep your momentum up for a few seconds
this speeds up the process of covering
an area in ink and introduces a new
wrinkle for splatoon veterans to explore
in addition to the rollers other change
it now spits out a vertical dash of ink
when used mid-jump those are just a few
of the things that we loved in splatoon
2's campaign and there will be plenty
more to experience once it comes out as
we get closer to the game's release
we'll have more videos for you but in
the meantime maybe some gameplay from
the new overwatch character dufus will
help satisfy your shooter itch if you
liked this video consider subscribing
and make sure to stay fresh
[Music]